je vous le disais en ouvrant ce journal
un avion d'air france assurant la
liaison régulière paris francfort a été
détourné en fin d'après-midi il est en
route vers beyrouth alors quels sont les
toutes dernières informations dont on
dispose gérard ce bague
et bien apparemment ce détournement dès
le début a pris une tournure assez
dramatique dans la mesure où l'on a
appris par le commandant de bord qui
s'est entretenu avec le chef de la
police à l'aéroport de genève il ya eu
un échange de coups de feu à l'intérieur
de cet appareil
on ne sait pas encore s'il ya des
victimes voici d'ailleurs le boeing 737
d'air france au décollage de genève
il y a à son bord je vous le rappelle 58
passagers et six membres d'équipage
il se dirige actuellement vers beyrouth
les autorités iraniennes ont refusé de
recevoir cet avion à téhéran
c'est en tout cas une affaire dramatique
qui risque d'empoisonner une nouvelle
fois les relations entre paris et
téhéran il faut dire que ces relations
sont effectivement assez mauvaise et
pour plusieurs raisons d'abord parce que
la france soutient depuis le conflit
entre l'irak et l'iran l'irak et
notamment en vendant du matériel
militaire à irak
les jaguars les exocet qui ont été
utilisés par les irakiens dans le golfe
persique